la communauté palestinienne de jérusalem
est se mobilisent hier de nouveaux
heurts ont éclaté dans le quartier de
cheikh jarrah lors d'une nouvelle
manifestation en soutien à quatre
familles menacés d'éviction profit de
colons israéliens en janvier dernier
l'onu a dénoncé ces ordres d'expulsion
considérant qu'il faisait partie d'un
schéma visant à changer la démographie
de la ville depuis plusieurs semaines
les rassemblements se multiplient ce qui
se passe n'est pas nouveau c'est le plan
de l'occupation israélienne dans le
quartier de cheikh jarrah
notre présence ici ne doit pas être que
par solidarité nous sommes propriétaires
des lieux et notre soutien à la
population de cake jarrah est un devoir
comme la prière et le jeûne
les soldats israéliens ont attaqué alors
que j'étais là en solidarité avec les
habitants du quartier de cheikh djarrah
avant qu'il ne soit expulsé de ce
quartier les tribunaux israéliens sont
racistes ils ne rendent pas justice aux
habitants du quartier et la décision du
tribunal qu'il s'agisse de la cour
suprême de la cour centrale ou de la
réconciliation
la décision est fait
ce qui signifie que les tribunaux sont
une imposture l'état hébreu s'appuie en
effet sur la loi sur les propriétés des
absents votée par la knesset en 1950
si des juifs peuvent prouver que leurs
familles vivaient à jérusalem est avant
la guerre de 1948 ils peuvent demander à
ce que leur soit rendu leur droit de
propriété
ce texte donne le droit à un dépositaire
désigné par le ministère des finances
d'expulser les occupants de certains
terrains revendiqués
lorsque la propriété dans la catégorie
des biens immobiliers est occupé par une
personne qui de l'avis du dépositaire
n'a pas le droit de l'occuper le
dépositaire peut confirmer ce fait par
un certificat signé de sa main
décrivant la propriété le certificat à
l'effet d'un jugement en faveur du
dépositaire pour l'expulsion de
l'occupant de la propriété acquise
existe aucune réciprocité dans cette loi
pour les palestiniens ayant perdu leur
droit pendant la guerre selon l'onu de
nombreuses familles palestiniennes
aurait déjà été expulsés à jérusalem est